welcome to episode 18 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i speak with chloe
valderri chloe valdry is an american
writer and entrepreneur whose company
theory of enchantment teaches social and
emotional learning in schools and
diversity and inclusion in companies and
government agencies
yeah you heard that right her company
teaches diversity and inclusion
in companies and government agencies now
that kind of description fills me with
dread
my first response to any anti-racism
chorus is disgust
i've seen what people teach at those
courses they teach white people to be
ashamed of being white
sometimes they separate people by race
and pit them against each other
sometimes these courses start as early
as grade 1. there are horribly racist
teachings under the guise of anti-racism
and i'm absolutely positive that the
minimum that these courses do is make
people angry
and the worst thing that they do is turn
non-racist people into racists
i found out about chloe because i was
tagged in a post she wrote about
beyonce's newest video album
she had intertwined my dad in her review
of the album
which i thought was somewhat
entertaining i watched a few of her
interviews and decided she might be
interesting to speak with
then i found out about the anti-racism
course so then i was a bit nervous
i saw that chloe had this anti-racism
company but i had also listened to her
interviews and so i figured why not have
a conversation about it
i don't see these anti-racism anti-bias
training initiatives leaving anytime
soon
even if there is a small push back
against them but perhaps if the people
who came in to teach these courses
weren't full of unbridled self-hatred
and malevolence
we could get through them without making
our political atmosphere even more
divided
i checked out chloe's course and while i
still don't think anti-racism courses
are a good idea
if we needed to take a course or if
there are business owners out there that
are mandated to provide anti-racism or
anti-bias training
chloe's course is what i would recommend
she doesn't come at you from a place of
hatred like a large number of these
courses do
she's well versed in stoicism and
philosophy
well-educated and i believe she really
wants to make the world a kinder place
without
tearing anyone down i think it's
important to talk about these topics and
find some sort of middle ground or north
america is going to be split in half and
i like north america
i ended up really enjoying our
conversation we talk about our course
about beyonce and about how to
communicate given how divisive
north america is right now if you're a
business owner being forced into
anti-racism and anti-bias training
see if you can use chloe's course
instead of something based off of
say robin d'angelo's white fragility
which we also get into on this podcast
if you enjoy this conversation and you
want to hear more remember to hit
subscribe
i hope you enjoy the episode
[Music]
chloe valderi welcome to my podcast
thanks for joining
thank you for inviting me appreciate it
this is going to be fun
i think this will be fun i invited you
on because i saw i don't know
who it was that tagged me in one of your
tweets and you were going by like a pl
you wrote like a play-by-play of
beyonce's um
black is king and you tagged my dad in
it and then somebody tagged me in it and
was like
comparing comparing jordan peterson to
beyonce and i was like who
is this chick and so i googled you
and then i saw i didn't see full
interviews but i saw clips of some of
the interviews you did and i was like oh
she's like been around kind of the idw
crew
yeah i've been i've been orbiting yeah
you have and some of the interviews were
really interesting so
i wanted to have you on um if we could
just start by
giving a brief background of who you are
and what it is you do
just in case anyone listening doesn't
know sure
so i'm chloe i have a really cool
business called theory of enchantment
which is
basically a startup that teaches people
how to love
it's a training program that uses
developmental psychology combined with
pop culture specifically to teach people
character building resiliency and how to
love themselves first
so that they can then learn to love
other human beings so that's what i do
mainly and then i comment on that and
then also like a hobby that i have is dj
uh which influences that heavily so
okay you're gonna need to go into a bit
about what the theory of
enchantment is and how you can possibly
teach people to
teaching people to love that sounds like
a huge
job especially right now when there's so
much
hate yeah i mean i created theory of
enchantment about a year and a half ago
i come from an international studies
background
in the world of conflict and diplomacy
there's a lot of frameworks about how to
uh combat conflicts but there's not a
lot of there's like no frameworks about
how to actually teach people how to love
which
as you pointed out is a real practice
that requires work
um and i would say like ritualistic
practice
um so i was at the wall street journal
for a year in 2015 where i worked on
this thesis paper
that ended up becoming the catalyst for
theory of enchantment
and the thesis was like okay if i want
to teach people how to love i actually
have to ask well what are people already
in love with
and see if i can use that as a conduit
to build a framework to teach them how
to love
and then the biggest source of content
that showed me what people were already
in love with was pop culture
and so from there i was like oh wait
what if there's a common denominator
across
different elements of pop culture so
like during this research that i
that i did i started studying companies
like nike
started studying companies like disney
started studying companies like
or influencers rather like beyonce to
see if there was like a common thread
and the common thread was all of these
companies and all these influencers
created content where their audience saw
themselves and their potential
reflected in the content and that's why
we bought it as consumers
and so it's like oh i have to create
something where people can see
themselves in their potential
and that and then they will learn how to
love themselves from there and then they
will learn how to love other human
beings
and so after i finished the paper i
worked for a non-profit for two years
basically my time was spent lecturing on
college
campuses giving like a 45 minute stump
speech on my whole theory of enchantment
and um i came up with three principles
to center it around
real really quick the principles are you
know treat people like human beings not
political abstractions
criticized to uplift and empower never
to tear down never to destroy
and root everything you do in love and
compassion so i would give like a 45
minute speech on this
and increasingly people were like you
know this is not just relevant to
conflict and diplomacy
it's relevant to social emotional
learning to interpersonal
relationships um to you know development
in high schools you should consider
branching out somehow and building this
into something more
so enough people told me that and i
decided to go for it um and then that 45
minute speech became a 25 lesson course
which is which is uh built around those
three principles that i mentioned
but i use pop culture to teach it so
there's a lot of um
you know there's there's nike ads
there's disney snippets
um there's stuff from james baldwin and
dr king there's
there's a lot of rich stuff we connect
uh stoicism to the lion king which is
really cool
um so yeah so that's the theory of
enchantment and that's what i do
professionally
so okay so let's back up a bit
how why like why teach
i mean i can see the niche and i can see
the need
but how did you get started teaching
people
how to love and and why
yeah i mean it's a good question as i
said my my background is in
international studies so when i was in
college i was super super heavy into the
pro-israel space
i had an israel advocacy club at the
university of new orleans
uh and every time we would try me my
friends we were trying to
like host events there were there always
be this like
loud back and forth boisterous bickering
that would just bubble up in audiences
and you know this isn't just
applicable to this particular topic we
see this in a lot of politics
these days and i could never understand
why
and it dawned on me that like the first
principles that were being used to guide
people's conversations
were incentivizing people to just get
angry at each other
and try and and try to tear each other
apart so
my interest was then well can we my
initial interest was then can we develop
a framework
that intensifies number one people not
to do that and people to do the opposite
people to actually want to
slow down and listen but even more than
that
want to actually understand that even if
you disagree
what matters more is compassion and
empathy even in the midst of profound
disagreement
and people are getting stuck on that so
i wanted to develop a framework to like
get people to
move out of that so so is this kind of
could it be used as a negotiating tool
kind of yeah i think i think you know
there are other people who are super
skilled and far more skilled in
negotiation
uh than i am but i think it could be
like a supplement to that definitely
okay what was the second what was the
second
like rule yeah yeah principle criticized
to uplift and
empower never to tear down or destroy
how do you do how can you give me an
example of how you would do that
yeah so that sounds sneaky and useful
so i mean it's all about remembering
that
your objective is to really produce
well-being
and human flourishing and so when you're
in an argument with someone or
disagreement with someone to remind
yourself that like
you want to criticize that person in a
way that
uh ensures that person that you care
about them not in a way that
makes them think that you're just being
prideful or you're just trying to you
know win an argument
um and the a cool story that i love to
tell about this is like
there's a really great story of when the
poet maya angelou
was on a film set with tupac she didn't
know who tupac was
and she saw him and he was
like about to get into a verbal
altercation
with another guy if not physical
altercation and he was sort of like
cursing under his breath
and she really didn't like that and she
says she said come on she said to him
come over here let me talk to you let me
talk to you
and he was still like mumbling under his
breath and like really irate
and then she's like come over here let
me talk to you let me talk to you and it
finally comes over and
she says don't you know that my
generation has been praying has been
yearning for your generation has been
counting on your generation to
to move us forward um and to and to
continue
the work that we did and we're counting
on you um
and the weight of everything that we
have done is upon your shoulders
um and then she proceeded to in that
context criticize his behavior
um and it was like i'm criticizing you
because i
i know you're capable of more than this
i know that you're capable of
far more potential than this and you're
not living up to your potential
and that's why i'm criticizing you
because i actually believe in you
um and then the story goes the very next
moment tupac started crying
uh because no one had ever criticized
him in
a way that indicated to him that they
believed in him
and so the very next day it wasn't like
tupac all of a sudden
with friends with this guy he almost got
to fight with but
uh whenever he would see maya angelou in
the hallway he would make sure that his
like composure was
was on point you know everything was
cool and he would make sure to say good
morning miss angelou and that's an
incredible story because
it proves that a person
cannot or will not change their
character will not even have the
potential changing their character
unless they are valued and this can be
very paradoxical right because if
someone is being
super obnoxious it's hard to
automatically think to yourself oh i
should care about this person
right that those person is attacking me
i should actually care about this person
and i actually respond to this person in
a way that suggests that i care about
them
um but that's the only kind of place
where we can come from
that has i think uh the chance of
actually getting people to change
and this was super super this way of
thinking was super influential
during the civil rights movement of the
50s and 60s like
folks like dr king would always talk
about like
we seek not the destruction
of the white races we seek this we see
this person is our brother this person
is our sister
right so we we don't like the sin
essentially um but we love the center
right which is obviously also a very
pervasive theme in christianity
um and so this is this is a theme that
has been a part of certain you know
american political movements
um and so my role is really to try to
curate
these moments and curate these sources
and put them into one
giant presentation and then try to
distribute and deliver it to people so
they can learn
just as i have learned wow that's
intense
yes uh do you think that's even possible
do you think that's possible on
platforms like twitter
or is twitter just doomed no
i gotta say i love twitter i think i
figured out twitter
um i think really yeah i need help
well what's your approach to twitter
like what like when you go on twitter
and you tweet something like what are
you thinking what's your mentality
uh generally i think it's just something
i'm interested in
but there's there isn't another social
media platform i find that you get
so much short like the the meanest
sentence you can come up with and the
fewest number of words
just aimed back at you from just
random people who probably would never
do that in person
and it's hard it's hard not to get
wrapped up in
that or wrapped up in the people you're
following if they all get irritated at
one
subject that comes out and then you know
you automatically have that response and
it's difficult i think i've
managed fairly well to step back a bit
to not
kind of get wound up and whatever
everyone else is getting wound up in but
it's very difficult
so how do you try and keep that kind of
boundary i think for me
because i am aware of a lot of like the
psychological back end
that informs people's decision makings
on platforms that are designed
to get them to become vengeful um
i can de-personalize it so when someone
responds to me in a way that's bitter
really i realize it has nothing to do
with me right has everything to do with
something going on in their life
and so for me it helps to remember that
and then i can
i can my response is a reflection of my
acknowledgement of the fact that has
nothing to do with me like
a couple of days ago someone i tweeted
something and someone was like this is a
really bad take and i'm like
well it may very well be a bad take i'm
a human being i make
i make mistakes you know but thank you
for taking the time out to actually
engage with this because you don't have
to you don't have to
you're taking the time out like i
appreciate that and so that totally like
that
and changes the situation so i don't
know for me it's just like a hack it's a
psychological
yeah yeah that's definitely not what
somebody on twitter is looking for
i think it's interesting though because
the more
i've recently like over the past four
months i'd say the more
i've tweeted with this kind of with
these kinds of
ideas in mind the more followers i've
gotten
in a short shorter period of time so
i i hear like i i hear this thing being
said all the time that like
and i and that there's some truth to it
like social media is designed for
us to be crazy and for us to respond
with our most base impulses but we still
have autonomy and we still have agency
and if
i think if we wanted to we could like
respond
collectively we could choose to respond
differently on
social media platforms like twitter and
the fact that there is that choice
makes me think that there's hope for
twitter okay i like that
i usually have to erase what i say a
bunch of times and then like eventually
i ended up
i end up doing something that like yeah
that's a that's what a reasonable person
would say
yeah but don't let it get to you
personally try
to de-personalize it remember like
a lot of most of the times when people
are acting
bitter or whatever there's something
going on in their own yeah
obviously i'm not talking about the
robots which is a different um
issue but when actual people when actual
people are
you know acting crazy there's something
going on in their own lives and like you
gotta de-personalize it has nothing to
do with you and
because you care about the well-being of
that person following principle two
i think it can at least just help train
me to
or condition me to think differently in
terms of my automatic response
so so that's under the assumption that
people don't actively want to bother or
harm
other people you're assuming people out
there actually care about other people's
well-being
well no i think what i'm assuming is
that people
can care not that people necessarily are
but that people can be persuaded to care
um and people can be persuaded to change
and that's the thing you you can't but
people can't change
unless you believe in the in their
capacity to change
right um so i don't think no it's
definitely not like
most people on twitter are necessarily
being like i'm gonna
go on twitter to just have a great day
today and put out positivity and
happiness
you know zooby do you follow zoobee on
twitter
well i don't follow him when i but i
interviewed him once for something but
yeah
well i i find his most of like i don't
know everything he tweets but a lot of
his
tweets are literally just hope everyone
out there has a good day
yeah i mean it's it's also it's also
like i
also want to challenge my audience on
twitter right it's not like it's not
like everything is you know
flowers and sunshine but so i definitely
challenge i think my twitter followers
with ideas and
but i also trust my audience that's the
other thing like i
even when people like i expect that some
people respond in a very
a harsh way but i actually trust my
audience to the point where even if i
engage that person i can talk to that
person in such a way where we might not
again we might not agree at the end
but we will come to an understanding
where we care about each other and i
think that's way more important
than trying to cultivate agreement you
know we're human beings of course we're
going to disagree
so hmm that's really cool
thank you you must be you must be like
emotionally stable
are you ridiculously emotionally like do
you get irritated easily or
does this come naturally to you or is
this something this is something i
worked on this is something i worked on
i mean i can tell you when
when colvid hit i i can't tell you it's
so it was so funny
because i was working on theory in
general before covet hit and when covert
hit i was like
i need to start meditating it's yeah it
just needs
because i knew that my nervous system
needed to calm down
because things were going to be so much
more stressful yeah
and i just knew that immediately that i
needed to implement that practice in my
life
so as soon as covet hit i started
meditating for an hour every day and i
haven't stopped
and that definitely affects my my
emotional stability
in a positive way some friends who i've
seen recently were like
you know you seem a little more zenned
out these days than
before and i was like that's because the
meditation is working so yeah no i
definitely
didn't automatically come into the world
with this but i have been actively
working on like prac and again like
practicing stoicism
is a part of the theory of enchantment
you know uh training so
um i have to i if i if i teach people
this i have to embody it as much as
possible otherwise it's like i'm a fraud
so
so that also plays a role you know
yeah okay uh what's the background how
did you end up
like i saw you were on dave rubin's
podcast
you've been on other like fairly big
podcasts so what was the spark like why
did you start getting invited on to
those things
was there something that led up to that
this is funny you'll find this funny
like with dave rubin dave rubin messaged
me on twitter in 2014
when he was just getting started i think
um that actually come on his podcast and
i was like yeah and then we
we like didn't hear from each other for
the next like five years
and then i saw your dad speak
in i think it was long island and
dave rubin was doing the modern he was
moderating it
uh and then i i remembered that he
messaged me
that's weird i remember that he messaged
me i was with a friend at the time we
were like we gotta get his attention
um and so he was he was outside after
after after the talk and we just walked
up to him and
i was like remember me and he was like
oh yeah chloe and he's like we got to
get you on the show and then that's how
i ended up getting on dave
oh that's that's a weird story yeah yeah
what did you think of the show
it was cool you know i'm really super
thankful today for giving me a platform
i um it was the first time i really
spoke about theory of enchantment i
think
at lymph on like a long long
uh format like for 45 minutes to an hour
which was cool i'm really happy that i
got to expound upon it
uh to his audience which is pretty
pretty big so it was it was really dope
um so this theory of enchantment who do
you you said you have a course a 25
lesson course yeah it's a 25 lesson
course
and what who buys it generally is it
like companies that buy it or
individuals so there's three segments
there's individuals
uh high schools and companies so
um yeah so those are the three sort of
like market segmentations that
that buy it wow
that's cool yeah check it out if you
want yeah yeah i want to
um i looked at it on your instagram page
and your instagram page for the theory
of enchantment it says that it's
teaching
part of it is teaching anti-racism which
i kind of want to delve into
because yeah yeah yeah i want to do this
and i want to talk
about the beyonce uh video too okay but
but starting with the anti-racism thing
so
my my experience over the last
well let's just say like six months
really because it's been a number of
years but particularly the last six
months is
i've never like thought of myself of
having as
having a race issue at all ever in my
entire life
and recently the talk with the black
lives matter movement
and the division on social media has
given me this
anxiety that i've never had um
so do you think
all the talk about like racial division
and black lives matter has that made
things worse for people
in the last couple of years than it was
like i swear when and maybe it's just
because i was a kid and i wasn't paying
attention
but i like i don't remember any of this
early 2000s and i didn't even think of
it and now it's like
no it wasn't a thing in the early 2000s
i think that instinct is correct
it is a it's definitely like a recent uh
recent hot topic if you will i think
that the conversation itself is fine
i think that it's fine that we're
talking about it i do think that there
are certain
uh there are certain
what would you say um things that are
being um
pitched as solutions to
the problem of racism the problem of
bigotry the problem of prejudice in
general
that are fundamentally bad
uh and they are being promoted as good
and my sense i mean i don't know for
sure but my sense is that
that's part of what's causing you to be
anxious
essentially um because you have a you
have a set of
i don't know what you would call them
pundits uh consultants that are that are
talking about racism
in a way that's very in my view
problematic
um and the solutions that they promote
are very problematic so when i think of
individuals i think of robin d'angelo
for example you know her book white
fragility is like
best seller right now so many companies
are
promoting it i i've read some of it
and it is one of the most fundamentally
i'm trying to think of the proper word
yeah yeah take your time take it
it's important it's important take your
time it's one it's one of the most
ironically narcissistic things i've ever
read
because because the premise is
the premise essentially is that like
quote unquote white people need to stop
centering themselves in the conversation
and here's this woman who we and we can
we can interrogate that premise whether
it's good or not right but
but what this woman is doing in order to
solve this apparent problem
is continuing to constantly just talk
about white people
and and and and and white people's
whiteness or whatever
um and what that does is is it creates a
feedback loop because what she's saying
to our people is that
you are racist you will always be racist
you are innately racist you are
socialized
to be racist and there's really nothing
you can do to
not be racist um which you know violates
all of the laws of the theory of
enchantment but but
but fundamentally violates the
first principle of a theory of
enchantment which is three people like
human beings
um not abstractions right and what she's
doing is she's treating people with a
certain skin color
as um in ways that are
basically just like racial essentialism
right she's saying to
to be white this must mean that you
engage in x y and z
now this this woman is assuming so much
about the complexity and the inner lives
of human beings
simply on-site based upon skin color and
she's doing that
and she's suggesting that that will be
somehow a solution to solving racism
when
when in fact it's the exact opposite so
i suspect
that much of the anxiety that people are
feeling is coming from
in part the fact that some people that
are claiming to
that they're going to successfully fight
or combat racism are actually going to
if not perpetuate racism um what they're
actually going to do is
make racism more appealing to people
and i'll explain what i mean by that um
if if you look at now i i think i from a
from a
psychology perspective i think i
actually understand where racism comes
from
um so racism is a form of extremism and
extremism
extremism has like a very specific
formula like it it it it
basically is very successful in a vacuum
so it's like on an
individual level what causes
extremism of any form including racism
is you have insecurity
usually it's both of a material and a
spiritual
um type so a person feels insecure
um and that insecurity sometimes leads
to self-contempt
and then that person overcompensates for
that self-contempt
and then that overcompensation sometimes
manifests itself in what is known as
supremacist ideologies
and racism is a kind of supremacist
ideology right so if you understand
that a lot of this stems from or at
least the kernel of a lot of this
is actually from comes from insecurity
then it is a really bad idea
if you want to end racism to do try to
do so by making people feel insecure
and making people feel more um um
anxious and or um
to make people feel self-content right
which is a serious piece of
robin deangelo's entire approach to how
to solve racism
um it's built into her to her solution
so
so i share your i guess you could call
it consternation
with a lot of what i'm what we're seeing
online
a lot of what we're seeing is this
so-called solutions
uh to to solving racism but i actually
think that my
my uh training is the actual way to
solve racism the actual it's a fight
against racism
it's rooted in dr king's vision of the
beloved community
it's rooted in the idea of treating
every single human being with the
dignity and respect
the respect that they deserve um and
it's rooted in
the concept of agape love which is you
know pervasive theme in christianity
you love a person uh because they
contain the divine image
because they're human beings um and so
that i think is the actual answer to
solving racism so that's why you saw in
the bio
on instagram that i yeah define theory
of enchantment as the best anti-racism
course
out there okay that's cool
huh interesting are you are you
christian
i act as if christianity
is a thing which i laugh because i got
that from your father um
i definitely i definitely didn't even
pick up on that
but yeah she's gonna she gonna get it no
no no
i miss a lot of jordan b peter like
people throw them at me all the time and
you're like
no yeah smile and nod anyway continue
so i grew up christian um i was raised
in a
in a in a sort of christian
home that was very similar to
seventh-day adventists so we went to
church on saturday instead of sunday
we observed rosh hashanah and yom kippur
instead of christmas
but we were practicing christians and so
that
tradition gave me a lot of tools it gave
me a
huge tool kit to do a couple of things
to detect patterns and to detect paradox
across cultures because as a christian
who grew up this way
i lived inside in like an insider
outsider
culture i wasn't a product of mainstream
christianity
right so um in that sense my tradition
was rebellious
um but all the things we did it was like
you must do this so it was also orthodox
at the same time and so that interplay
was something that taught me
just about paradox um and how reality
and life and culture can be so
paradoxical
and it also made me incredibly
cosmopolitan because it exposed me
to world traditions um you know we would
spend instead of instead of spending
december 25th around a christmas tree we
would spend december 25th studying the
origins of christmas
this is how this is how i grew up
um we would we would spend christmas
studying ancient documents written by
emperor constantine and
this is all in an effort to sort of like
get us to
quite frankly despise catholicism but
but what it did
but you're going to say think
well yes it also had that added benefit
um
but but what it did was expose me to the
to the fact of history right it made me
realize that like
the present moment is not the only thing
that
exists or certainly not the only thing
that has implications for the present
moment
um and so i was very much exposed to
ancient empires
um at an early age just like the fact of
ancient rome or the fact of ancient
persia
were topics that i was learning about
very early age
and that made me cosmopolitan um so
there is that
judeo-christian a pattern of
uh storytelling or just that that i
gravitate toward
more than probably any other tradition
did you if you don't mind me asking what
did your parents do
it's just that's an interesting way to
spend holidays
yeah so my my dad my dad is a banker and
my mom
is just a homemaker so they're just
chilling
chilling like a villain and doing their
thing
not two psychology professors that's
what it sounds like
you would think but no yeah but yeah
homemaking is tough so don't
underestimate that
i hear that i hear that yeah
um what did you say you took in
university international studies with a
concentration in diplomacy
yeah okay there's there was some
psychology in that
like i had to take some psychology yeah
of course yeah well you would for
for diplomacy that makes sense yeah okay
okay uh i want to get into
beyonce okay yes let's see so excited
yeah yeah um i like beyonce
i heard it here first guys
yeah i do like beyonce um what's
what's okay i'm i'm not gonna be able to
like bring up the songs properly but is
the song
hold up or is that just the main letter
from lemonade
i love that song yeah that was the name
of the song yeah
yeah yeah that's that's a great song um
that is a great song that's when she's
like carrying the bat did you see the
music video for that yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's great yeah that's
a great song
um okay anyway so she just put out this
video album called black as king
and you broke it down on twitter so i
wanted to get
your thoughts on that and i and i put up
something on instagram
that was like you know i'm doing this
podcast ask your questions
and i mentioned beyonce and a bunch of
people were like you know
what the hell does beyonce have to do
with anything
i was like we're gonna get into that and
see if she has anything to do with
anything
so um can you give i didn't watch the
entire thing because
i'm in serbia and it's on disney plus
and
band here so that's so sad
right um but i watched two thirds of it
and my response to it because i'm very
skeptical and i'm also
very skeptical about like where there's
ideology anywhere i'm like are they
trying to
put something in there yeah yeah
exactly and so i watched it and i'm like
super skeptical watching it even though
i like beyonce
and um there was i think there were
two maybe like three second
parts in the first two thirds of it
that i kind of got like that discomfort
feeling
but then i broke it down and i thought
okay why
like why is this making me um
uncomfortable
and and then i decided
like it's very pro being black
and i was like does that mean like does
that is that anti-white
that was my thing it's like is that
anti-white i automatically answer it
yeah exactly and i watched two-thirds
and i decided it wasn't
um so that was like the conclusion i
came to
and and the reason i and i was like well
is it okay that
you know she came out with an album and
it's called black is king
and if you put an album out right now
that said white is king
yeah it wouldn't go over well correct
and so that's making like a lot of the
people i think that responded to
any irritation that beyonce was like
well why why isn't that okay
and just because and which i think is
wrong that that's not okay but that
doesn't mean that what she did
is not okay yeah that's a good point
yeah
yeah i think that's right i i think
but i also think like because i've
received this question a lot also
on my on my twitter it's
a it comes from a lot of people who
didn't see it because like when i
watched it the title made sense to me
because the title
specifically seems to come from a very
particular scene
in the visual album where uh it's like i
don't know if you've got this far but
it's like a chess board
and the characters the
the the opponents are there's one side
painted in all black and there's one
side opinion yeah
yeah i got past that yeah yeah and then
you see you hear jay-z talking about
duality of
light and dark of good and evil and how
these things play a role
uh in a sort of delicate balance with
each other
and that is the scene that is the
context
for which and you hear another piece of
voice over where someone is saying
you know in order to act keenly
or in order to be kingly i have to try
to act as as though a king would
right um and so if taken from the
derived from that scene and i think it's
supposed to be derived
from that scene the meaning of the title
it has absolutely nothing whatsoever to
do with skin color
actually it's it's actually a commentary
on
do duality um that is a part of life
and the fact that especially when you
take the chess metaphor
you know you you have a black king
anyway king
right um it's not really about skin
color
or per se it's it's really about
something much more deeper and there's a
much
more sophisticated i think statement
about the hero's journey that's being
made
um through the through that title but
you only come to that conclusion or
it's only you're only capable of coming
to that conclusion if you watch it
and what sucks is that for some the
title is itself
a barrier to entry um you know it's like
some some people are like oh i assume
this is a
racially supremacist thing because of
the title and it's like yes
it's not give it a try watch it it's so
much deeper
um so she did a good job yeah she did a
really good job it's really
beautiful it's really beautiful and also
it's very
much uh i want i wanted to talk to you
about like what you thought of this
because i just finished
maps of meaning like a month ago that's
intense
yeah i haven't read that in a long time
so you're going to definitely
be like more well-versed in it that is
an
intense book why would you do that to
yourself
i mean i watched the 12 part series from
like 2017
and i was obsessed and i was just like
well i guess i gotta
read the original the original source
um so yeah i wat i read it from cover to
cover and
what it what it made me realize is that
like beyonce
in a lot of the imagery that she uses
and certainly
in black is king basically embodies a
lot of the
descriptions that your father makes uh
of the archetype of the divine feminine
like this is what she's doing on purpose
she's
she specifically um plays with these
this kind of imagery
yeah throughout all of her work not just
black's king but especially you know in
black as king she like
becomes this sort of benevolent mother
uh like that's the archetype that she
embodies and
it's brilliant because it's taking the
story of the lion king
and it's it's turning it into real life
it's telling the story of
african-americans
of this and it's the hero's journey
story it's a story of
exile and then rebirth it's a story that
that encourages um heeding the wisdom of
your elders right which is something
that
that obviously jordan peterson talks
about it's a story of
um a lot of elements that are part of
that i found him out to meeting and also
you know joseph campbell's
hero with a thousand faces but she in
particular embodies
specific cultural traditions in which
this concept of the divine
mother of the benevolent mother has
repeated itself and it's in christianity
so she she does
she pays certain olds to christianity in
it but it's also
yeah but it's also in the yoruba
religion of nigeria and a lot of the
scenes
are in nigeria and a lot of the artists
that she performs with are nigerian and
so she embodies that as well
um so i don't know i just find it
fascinating i'm obsessed with archetypes
i'm a nerd when it comes to that um and
i think
it's it's an incredibly beautiful and
rich artistic expression of
a people's exile and in return which is
what which is what you know
the lion king is about but to put it to
try to
to use it to speak to the experience of
the lived people of an actual group of
people
is quite beautiful and one more thing
i'll say about it and i'll stop
is it's not parochial because after all
we all come from africa
ultimately right and so anyone i think
um i think out of the particular lives
of the universal and anyone can
see themselves reflected in this in this
work regardless of your skin color so i
encourage people to go watch it because
it's one of the most beautiful things
i've seen
yeah and if you're not going to watch
the whole thing at least watch the scar
scene because the scar is so cool oh
it's so good yeah
yeah he's got this giant snake wrapped
around him it's yeah
it's pretty cool yeah that's awesome
okay so what is your you have this
theory of enchantment what's your plan
with that what's your goal
is there a direction you're trying to go
in are you just seeing what happens
world domination um
that'd be that wouldn't be bad like from
what i know about your theory of
enchantment i can see
worst world domination yeah i mean i
really want to scale it i want
you know as many especially because
companies are bringing in
anti-racism training i want as many
companies to
to come come to the theater and share
the universe
and um really see what we we have to
offer because i think
like even for individuals who are
currently enrolled some of the
testimonials that i'm getting back
are like beyond my wildest dreams so
it's a really powerful program
um so i want as many people high schools
uh companies to enroll in it to learn
from it to spread the word
um and ultimately yeah just you know
casually world domination so
so business this is actually pretty
smart because business-wise this and
this
anti-racism training i don't think is
going away
like it's not just a little it's not a
little thing that popped up and people
are going to ignore
and i think a lot of those programs are
really poisonous um
and i think a lot of them like you said
before are probably just breeding racism
yeah so or at the very least just like
resentment
yeah which leads to irritation
yeah which is terrible especially under
the guys that
especially oh and yeah it means it's
just
share your frustrations
trying to get in that's actually a
really good idea trying to get in
there and be like what about doing
things the right way
what if we study the writings of dr king
guys
what let's let's do that like let's
let's study
the incredibly rich uh
texts of folks like dr king and maya
angelou and james baldwin and let's
seriously try to see
how we can build a society or build
culture
in your workplace around
these value systems and like and and
that's that's
integrated diversity and inclusion right
that's real diversity and inclusion
but you're not just for example i've
seen this a lot people put up
james baldwin quotes without actually
seriously studying james baldwin
um but it's like i'm going to ask you
to come with me on this journey to
actually seriously
uh study james baldwin and to try to
apply what you learn
to your life not only as a white person
but as a human being fundamentally
in order to bring about flourishing
across the human condition so
yeah i think it's an amazing course so i
would love for
more and more people to to get involved
okay i'll have to check that out
after maybe i'll check it out actually
before
we release the podcast okay
do some sort of intro and know what i'm
talking about i'll probably
do that um okay what other questions do
i have for you
uh okay so say say
you're about to get tangled up with
somebody on um
well in person wherever online in person
and you guys are coming from things at
completely
different angles um and you both have
your own ideologies that are completely
clouding your judgment
um what's the what's the best thing you
can do to try and
get through to someone and are there
some people that you
just say maybe this is maybe it's better
not to engage
yeah definitely i mean they're only 24
hours in a day you know so
one must be discerning about how they
allocate their time
um but other than that
so in this scenario am i caught up in an
ideology
and i'm talking to someone well i mean
i would assume that most people when
they're arguing with someone
even if they're in an idol ideology
probably don't think they are
so say no you're not
okay but they are yeah
okay um i would try to
it depends on the topic obviously like
this is a very broad question but
i would try to use something
that they're familiar with to prove my
point
which like is both
enchanting i think but also confusing
because it it
it's not what you what you would expect
um
so like for example this whole thread
about beyonce and jordan peterson is
like
which side am i on here no i know it was
great
it confused it honestly it confused me
because i was like
most of the guests i well no i do i do
two things i have
people who are really involved in diet
and health and i just completely
nerd out on that end which i'm sure half
of my audience has absolutely
no interest in and then the other people
i talk to are probably people my dad was
more
like got me into more so that's kind of
the idw
and you know one would argue that's
slightly
right of center so i was going through
your tweets and i was like i don't know
man
is this i was like i was talking to
andre's my husband and i was like like
look at these tweets is
is she like is she like far left and
she's just
really smart like i need to get a good
night's sleep before i talk to this girl
just in case i'm like i need to be
careful here but it was
really hot that makes me so happy
it's confounding it is well that's good
though that's kind of that's kind of
what you don't want to
just go through somebody's tweets and
it's like yeah
that's that person in a box yeah but
but also in addition i'd say another
tool is to just like even if you have to
agree to disagree and say try to try to
do so in a way that uh
reflects your ultimate belief in their
well-being
right you don't have to come away from
that conversation having resolved
everything
it is after all a twitter conversation
that we're talking about here
um but you can communicate to them
in in a way that where it's clear that
you like
you're not trying to diss them or
dehumanize them even though you disagree
you still care very much about them and
i think that that at the end of the day
is the most important
one of the most important messages we
could get out especially right now
in these very trying times yes these are
very trying times
i'm sure the meditation is a good idea
too
yeah like i encourage everyone to start
meditating
yeah i was i was using are you just
doing it
like or do you have is it guided are you
just sitting there and
letting your mind wander well i use an
app called insight timer but it's
the only thing that i use it for is the
like bell
to indicate when the 60 minutes are up
so
other than that no it's just me and my
thoughts
i guess but like but like i'm
it's not that bad i'm like basically
what you learn how to do
is the way i learned meditation was like
you
it's not that there's something wrong
with thinking
while you're meditating you just need to
remember that you're thinking
right and so if you cut if you find
yourself
starting to think about something that's
totally fine that you shouldn't feel
guilty for that
you just remind yourself oh that is a
thought right and then and then the more
that happens the more you can train
yourself to like
pull yourself out of um in some cases
thoughts that just spiral loops
yeah exactly and i think that's a muscle
that has to be trained and that's what
meditation does is it trains that muscle
okay i need to do that more i was using
head space
um because i was like i don't have the
patience to meditate i can do 10 minutes
a day like
if you can't do 10 minutes of meditation
a day you're just lying about not being
able to meditate
so i was like i don't have any excuse to
not meditate for 10 minutes and it has
this
well it's guided and it tells you to
fill up your body kind of with gold
so then you have to bring yourself back
to
visualizing this gold and i was just
having a hell of a time because it's
just like
loops and spirals out and into nowhere
and 10 minutes would be over and be like
oh my god i forgot to fill up myself
with gold
maybe maybe maybe your way
are they talking the entire time no
that's the problem
like it would be better if they're like
remember what you're doing and focus on
this gold thing
yeah but they're not they they pause for
a little bit too long and then
you stop thinking like you can't focus
on filling yourself up with gold for
that long so
yeah i think that would that would
irritate me because i would just want
the freedom
to think about whatever i want to think
about yeah see that but
the person who speaks is australian so
the accent is
really nice yeah okay yeah yeah yeah i
could see that i don't know it's not as
irritating
yeah that's fair i just do it to and i
also do it in nature so i go to a local
park
and so like once i found i used to do it
inside but i found that when you do it
in nature
basically after it's over especially
after 60 minutes of meditating
the your understand your like
view of reality is at a higher
resolution
yeah i'm not surprised at all yeah and
it's like whoa
which is cool it's a cool experience oh
do you do it with your eyes closed
yeah wow
one day one day i will one day i will be
there
maybe when i'm not in serbia where are
you right now
i'm in new york the legendary
yeah how's new york doing are things a
little bit more normal
yeah it's it's good it's hot outside
you know school is about to start so
that'll be interesting
um but no i think it's yeah
for them and also like brooklyn is a
very neighborhoody town
so it's not as as much of a ghost town
that like manhattan was in the beginning
so in terms of like seeing people out on
the streets and stuff it's been fairly
normal the entire time so um
that's good yeah yeah that's good
yeah how's serbia um it's
full of coronavirus turns out oh really
yeah it sucks yeah it turns it's it's
not that
it's not that bad i like serbia scurvy
is nice i don't think anybody from like
north america they don't really go to
belgrade to visit
yeah that i know of like croatian things
belgrade's really cool
i recommend it it's also cheap for north
americans
and it's really easy to get around
everyone here speaks english
which i wasn't expecting yes that's cool
yeah let's go explore belgrade after the
pandemic is
gone yes in like two or three years
oh you think it's gonna be that long
i have no idea i l like i have no idea
yeah i hope not to i hope not to
um okay well that was fun
i'm really glad i got you on and thank
you and sorry for rescheduling a whole
bunch of times but
no it's totally cool i'm definitely down
to be friends if you want
um we should talk about art and [ __ ] if
you're cool with that as well sorry i
don't know if i can curse on this
podcast you can cut that part anyway
that's okay i had somebody on a couple
weeks ago and every second word was [ __ ]
and yeah it was intense it was fun
though so it was okay
okay cool but yeah yeah let me know what
you're up to
and i will check out your course and
i'll update people in the intro i think
because that sounds really it sounds
really necessary right now because oh
i have got one more question okay okay
um
the black box thing that happened
what's up on instagram did you not know
about the black box thing on instagram
that it was like it was like two months
ago what were you
talking about like a plane or something
oh god no no
no this is less yeah this is less
intense than that but
how did you feel about the everybody
putting up a black box and
inside you didn't put up a black box no
no you you asked me how did i feel and i
said i did not
i did not know anything about that okay
okay so that was another thing and
and i try when i get really irritated
about something i try and like step back
and wonder why i'm getting irritated and
if i'm in the right to get irritated
uh well i have this pop it's not a
policy it's just how i am now
there are certain things that i might
you know have a casual opinion on where
like this is kind of pointless or this
is kind of silly or just
you know doesn't do anything um
the black boxing is was probably one of
those things if i
but i but my point is i didn't give more
than
like five minutes of thought to that so
that seems healthy that's like that
sounds like a
healthy response meditation i'm telling
you it's the game changer
it's a total it might be that it might
be that yeah i got
all worked up about the black box i was
like this is this is one of those things
that people are saying means something
that it doesn't
oh it just i guess it didn't bother me
also because i'm aware
of the of how fleeting social media
is like it's there's so many things that
are discussed with
such passion and ad nauseam
that only lasts for like
two days yeah and then we're on to the
next topic like
so i extend my energy to something that
i know is not going to be talked about
next week you know so yeah
that's like a regulator yeah
yeah we'll see maybe that one hour
meditation if i ever start that that'll
help with this i doubt it though i think
it's just my personality we'll see
you literally just told me if you say
that you can't meditate for 10 minutes
you're lying yeah i i stand by that
but i feel like that applies to how can
not meditating
for for however long it doesn't matter
be a per it's i don't think it's a
personality thing
we'll see i'll get there i know i know
i'll get there i can see it in my future
awesome okay where can i direct people
where can people find you online
people can go to theory of
enchantment.com
um check out the site we have a free
we're gonna have a free course up there
soon probably by next week
free mini course on how to fight racism
um
so check that out also you can follow me
on twitter
and on instagram at seavaldery and also
at theory of enchantment
cool well thank you very much thank you
for having me
[Music]
you